ينضم الينا في الاستوديو اسامه عيدروس
الخبير في الشؤون السياسيه والعسكريه
السودانيه السيد عدار روسيا اليوم كان
هناك تكثيف
بالانفجارات على في محيط القصر الجمهوري
ايضا الدعم السريع استهدف مواقعه تمت
استهداف مواقعه في ضواحل الخرطوم
ما الذي يحدث على الارض ما الذي يحاول كل
طرف انجازه
في ظل مفاوضات فقط تتحدث عن مواضيع
انسانيه وربما مؤقت لاطلاق النار تابعت
معك قبل قليل على الخارطه معركه الجسور في
الخرطوم وهي تلخيص حقيقي للصراع الان منذ
بدايته حتى الان
بدايه الصراع ان الدعم السريع كان متغلغل
داخل العاصمه الخرطوم ويبدو انه حضر داخل
العاصمه الخرطوم بشكل كبير حيث كان يعني
التقارير تقول انه كان لديه اكثر من 80
معسكر هو موجود في الاذاعه في التلفزيون
في محيط القياده في القصر الجمهوري في كل
مكان كان موجود بقواته
فحينما حصلت الضربه الاولى يعني كانت قويه
جدا
احتاج الجيش الى زمن قبل ان يستعيد يمتص
الصدمه ويستعيد زماما المبادره بعد ذلك
بدا الجيش في تنفيذ عمليه يمكن ان نسميها
استباق عمق قوات الدعم السريعه او التمرد
الذي حصل داخل العاصمه استباق العمق يعني
بقطع الاطراف البعيده بحيث انه لا يكون
لهذه القوات اعتماد على اي امداد ياتي من
مكان بعيد خصوصا في الولايات دارت معارك
الولايات الدعم السريع كانوا يركز في ذلك
الوقت على المطارات
والمعسكرات التي يستطيع منها شل حركه
القوات المسلحه وكان الهجوم على مطار مروي
والقاعده العسكريه في كرري وفشل في في
تحقيق اي نجاح طبعا في نجاحات وتراجع لكن
فشل في السيطره على اي هذه من هذه القواعد
العسكريه الجيش نجح في انه يسيطر على
مجريات الام في 17 ولايه لا نقول انه كل
شيء انتهى هناك لكن استطاع السيطره تماما
على الاطراف وبالتالي نقل
المعركه الى ما يمكن ان نسميه الدفاع في
العمق الاستراتيجي للجيش نفسه طيب الان ما
هو تفسيرك لهذه
المباحثات التي تجري في جده والتي ما زالت
تراوح مكانها هل ترى بان كل طرف يحاول اي
ماطل يكسب الوقت حول السيطره على الارض
لتحقيق اهداف
لاحقا من المؤكد انه الملف السوداني ملف
شائك لانه السودان نفسه دوله ذات موقع
استراتيجي تقع في منطقه ملتهبه جدا فيها
صراع ايرادات دوليه منطقه الساحل والصحراء
كلها
روسيا داخل
فرنسا بقواتها وجيشها المجموعات امراء
الحرب الممتده في ليبيا
وغيره فالملف السوداني شائك والتدخل
الدولي كان كبير جدا خلال الاربع سنوات
لدرجه وجود المبعوثين الدوليين
والسفراء داخل القصر الجمهوري وكانهم
يديرون البلد ويحركون الامور هذه
المفاوضات حرصت يعني
حرص الجيش على ان يقول انها مفاوضات ذات
طبيعه ترتيبات امنيه مختصه بالهدنه
الانسانيه كرر هذا الامر اكثر من مره والح
عليه عبر السفراء وعبر المبعوثين
الرئاسيين وعبر الناطق الرسمي للجيش وكانه
هنالك خشيه من ان يتم سرقه هذه المفاوضات
لانه الاطراف الاقليميه والدوليه بما فيها
اسرائيل ودول اقليميه مجاوره
ودول اوروبيه
وحتى المبادره نفسها جزء منها الامريكان
يعني كان هنالك خشيه ان يكون هنالك مشروع
مخفي
يراد فرضه على السودان من خلاله توقف هذه
الحرب او تستمر يعني حسب المشروع نفسه هذه
الخشيه من ان تتحول هذه المفاوضات من
هاتفها الذي اقيمت من اجله وهو الهدنه
الانسانيه نسبه يعني معركه الخرطوم تسببت
في دمار البنى التحتيه تسببت في الام
كثيره جدا للسودان وكل الذين يموتون فيها
ابناء السودان فالهدنه الانسانيه كان يمكن
ان تطور يعني حتى الجيش نفسه يعرف انه
تطوير النجاح واستغلاله يعني اذا كانت
بدات الهدنه الانسانيه
ونجحت على الارض وخففت من الام السودانيين
يمكن بعد ذلك ان ينجح السودانيين في
الخروج بمشروع سوداني سوداني خالص يحقق
استقرار الدوله السودانيه قبل ان يفرض
عليه اي مشروع غربي شكرا
السياسيه والعسكريه السودانيه شكرا لك على
الافاده